أكثر من 3.5 مليون حالة إجمالية ،
ما يقرب من
150000 حالة وفاة وإحصاء العديد من الفاشيات في
جميع أنحاء أمريكا اللاتينية ومنطقة البحر
الكاريبي لا تتحسن ، وكبار مسؤولي الصحة
الإقليميين لا يفرطون في الكلمات ، لقد شهدنا
أسبوعًا آخر كسر الأرقام القياسية حيث أبلغت
النقاط الساخنة الإقليمية
عن أعلى حالة يومية على الإطلاق
يحسب
النقاط الساخنة مثل البرازيل التي تجاوزت الآن
مليوني حالة
لأول مرة
بين هؤلاء ، رئيسها
والمتشكك في فيروس كورونا جاير بولسونارو الذي
أثبتت إصابته مرتين هذا الأسبوع
[موسيقى]
يقول إنه يشعر بصحة جيدة ويريد
العودة إلى
العمل لأكثر من 75  لا تتوفر هذه الفرصة لألف برازيلي ممن
لقوا حتفهم بسبب هذا الفيروس
، وفي الوقت نفسه ، فإن
المكسيك مع أكثر من
37000 حالة وفاة تتبع فقط البرازيل
والولايات المتحدة
في إجمالي الوفيات في جميع أنحاء العالم ، لكن هذا الرسم البياني
يوضح اتجاهًا واضحًا من
المحتمل أن تتفوق فيه المكسيك على وفاة المملكة المتحدة
حصيلة الضحايا
في غضون أسابيع فقط بالإضافة إلى
علامات مقلقة في البلدان الأصغر في جميع
أنحاء المنطقة
في غواتيمالا حيث بلغت الحالات ستة أضعاف
أعلى مما كانت عليه قبل ستة أسابيع ،
قال الأطباء لوكالة فرانس برس إنهم يخشون
أن تنهار المستشفيات
وسط دعوات لمزيد من المساعدة من
الحكومة ،
هذا الطبيب يقول إن ما يقتلنا
ليس الفيروس ، بل هو
لامبالاة الدولة ، إنه لامبالاة
السلطات الصحية
وفي بوليفيا ، كان عدد الحالات
أعلى بخمس مرات مما كان
عليه في الأول من يونيو
، أعلنت الرئيسة البوليفية أنها
وسبعة وزراء على الأقل
مصابون بالفيروس
حيث تستمر مقاطع فيديو مثل هذه في
تعميم السلطات التي لا
تستطيع جمع جثث
خليج مشتبه به.  ضحايا
هذا الجار يقول إننا نطلب من
السلطات من فضلك لا يمكنك ترك
جثة هنا
مرت أكثر من 12 ساعة وهذا
خطر على العائلات التي تعيش
بالقرب من
مأساة الفيروس التاجي شيء
مألوف لدى جار أمريكا الجنوبية تشيلي
إنه أكثر من  320000 حالة من بين
أعلى المعدلات في العالم
لكنها سجلت هذا الأسبوع أقل من
2000 حالة جديدة في اليوم مرتين
لأول مرة.  منذ منتصف مايو ، إنها
أخبار جيدة
في منطقة يمكن أن تستخدم بعض
أمريكا اللاتينية ومنطقة البحر الكاريبي لا
تزال واحدة من
البؤر الرئيسية لوباء كرونوفيروس ، حيث
يوجد الآن أكثر من ثلاثة ملايين
حالة
في المنطقة وعدد الوفيات في العديد
الدول تواصل تسلق البرازيل يوم
السبت أعلنت أنها
سجلت ألف حالة وفاة جديدة
وهذا شيء مأساوي
أصبح الآن
أكثر وأكثر تكرارا
خلال الأسابيع العديدة الماضية أه
كان هناك عدد القتلى في
البرازيل
من ألف  شخصًا كل يوم أو أكثر
، أعلن رئيس البلاد جاريد
بولسونارو الأسبوع الماضي أنه
أصيب أيضًا بفيروس
كورونا
أه يتناول الأدوية
وسيخضع للعزل لمنع
انتشاره للسيدة البرازيلية الأولى التي
أعلنت زوجته يوم السبت
أنها  تم اختباره وحتى الآن
جاءت نتائج الفحص سلبية لفيروس كورونا أه
وكذلك رئيس بوليفيا الرئيس
المؤقت لبوليفيا  جنين ونعم وكثير
من أعضاء حكومتها
أثبتوا إصابتهم بالفيروس أه هناك أيضًا
عدد من المسؤولين رفيعي المستوى في
فنزويلا
ثبتت إصابتهم بالفيروس ، بينما من
الواضح أن فيروس كورونا
يميل إلى التأثير على
الفقراء وهناك فجوة كبيرة في الثروة.
العديد من بلدان أمريكا اللاتينية ومنطقة البحر الكاريبي ،
لكننا نرى بشكل
متزايد كبار المسؤولين الحكوميين
الذين يتأثرون أيضًا ،
ونرى أيضًا ظاهرة عدد من
البلدان
التي يبدو أن لديها فيروس كورونا تحت
السيطرة
تعلن عن عمليات إغلاق جديدة كما هو الحال في
كولومبيا كما في كوستاريكا
و  يظهر فقط أن مخاطر
إعادة الفتح في بعض
الأحيان يمكن أن تتسبب في كثير من الأحيان في إعلان العديد من البلدان في تلك
المناطق عن عمليات إغلاق أكثر صرامة لتضطر
إلى التراجع عن بعض
إعادة الفتح لأنهم بدأوا في
رؤية عدد الحالات يرتفع مرة أخرى
وتتصارع أمريكا الوسطى والجنوبية
مع طفراتهم الخاصة في كوفيد
برازيل ، بيرو تشيلي المكسيك ، فإنهم يحتلون
قائمة العشرة الأوائل من البلدان التي لديها أكبر عدد
الحالات
المؤكدة تكافح دول منطقة البحر الكاريبي أيضًا
للسيطرة على الفيروس وتوفي أكثر من 121000
شخص بسبب فيروس كورونا في
منطقة البحر الكاريبي وأمريكا الجنوبية
حتى الآن ، لكن دولة جزيرة كوبا
تمكنت من التغلب على هذا الاتجاه حوالي 2  400
حالة مؤكدة حتى الآن في كوبا و 87
حالة وفاة باتريك أوبن من سي إن إن ينضم إلينا على
الهواء مباشرة من هافانا الآن
باتريك نعم عدد سكان كوبا واحد
فقط يزيد قليلاً عن 11 مليون نسمة
ولكنهم ما زالوا قادرين على تسوية
المنحنى كما يقولون بنجاح أكبر من
جيرانها  هنا في نصف الكرة الأرضية لدينا ،
أخبرنا
لماذا هي صورة مختلفة تمامًا هنا
اليوم فقط يوم السبت وفقًا
لمسؤولي الصحة الكوبيين ،
كانت هناك سبع حالات فقط
في هذه الجزيرة كما قلتم والتي
يبلغ عدد سكانها 11 مليون نسمة
ووفاة واحدة وهي أول وفاة.
مرتبطًا بفيروس كورونا
في أسبوعين تقريبًا أه
مختلف تمامًا عن بقية أمريكا
اللاتينية وأنت تعرف هذا كيف يعمل
لديك حكومة  في لديه
سلطة كاملة لإخبار الأشخاص بارتداء
أقنعة الوجه التي قاموا بها ، حيث يتم نقل أي
شخص يمرض إلى المستشفى حتى في
بعض الأحيان يتم نقل
الأشخاص الذين كانوا على اتصال بهم والذين كانوا على
اتصال بهم إلى المستشفى
كإجراء وقائي
وهكذا تعرف في البداية  كان هناك بعض
القلق من أنه نظرًا لأن كوبا لا
تملك الموارد التي تمتلكها الدول الأخرى
أه تفعل ذلك فهي تخضع للعديد من
العقوبات الأمريكية التي كانت
لعقود من الزمان لدرجة أن كوبا لن تكون قادرة
على التعامل بشكل مناسب
مع هذا الوباء أه ولكن
كان العكس تمامًا  أغلقت كوبا حدودها
، ولا توجد سياحة هنا في الوقت الحالي
كانت مكلفة
للغاية لهذا البلد ، ولكن كان من
الفعال للغاية أنه لا يمكنك الحصول على المزيد من
الحالات في الذئب وتمكنت الحكومة
من البدء ببطء في إعادة
فتح الاقتصاد.  عدد قليل من
الأحياء في هافانا تحت الإغلاق
ولكن ما رأيناه خلال الأسبوع الماضي
الآن هو إعادة فتح الشركات حتى
الشاطئ وإعادة فتح
السؤال المهم هو متى
المطارات عندما تبدأ
في إعادة فتحها لأنه بمجرد أن تبدأ في السماح
للسائحين بالعودة ،
فإنك تخاطر بإعادة تعريض
السكان لهذا الفيروس
ولكن في الوقت الحالي ، تتغلب كوبا بطريقة ما
على فيروس كورونا
صورة مختلفة تمامًا عن الكثير
دول أخرى في المنطقة